good morning
Millennials welcome back to the chose
and happy Oh my God Wednesday
okay okay okay Wednesday I see
you you're looking gorgeous today
Wednesday Wednesday you're looking fine
you really are I can't believe it's
Wednesday I love that for us yeah
exciting to really just be thrust into
the latter half of the week 100% I love
a good
thrusting it is not one but two deg here
in New York it is so cold you guys if
you wondering why it looks like a freak
I have a heating pad on my legs like I
literally can't get warm today it's so
crazy here like it's like the whole
street is white and it's not snow do you
know that feeling like when it's so cold
I don't know what the hell that is yeah
I see well this would be a good time to
tell you guess the temperature here
today 65 and sunny 65 and sunny that's
what you wear in 65 and sunny well
actually it was 63 and not exactly sunny
but not cloud like not a lot of sun yeah
and you know I dress for the show and
your studio is freezing not necessarily
the climate though I was out this
morning and this was the perfect thing
for the weather cuz it was like 63 and a
little baly it was really beautiful
perfect the baly balm and you know I
love a
balm I love the Met balm I'm going to go
to the Met balm so today's Wednesday
which means a lot of things
things one it's hump day and I just feel
like I would be I people are always
telling me Claudia like use your
platform for good and that's what I'm
about to do do not forget to hump
someone you love today who are you going
to hump since your mans is out shopping
in Los Angeles oh my God you're right
like I'm kind of a loner you've got to
find a hump oh well I have an
appointment today with Dr gey for some
Botox so she's probably the only person
like I'll come in contact with
today so gge loins Dr gey I'm coming for
you I need
Botox it's time I mean yeah well I'm
breastfeeding right now so I can't get
BOTOX but the minute I'm done I was
actually thinking this morning of all
the things I need to do and how I just
kind of like want to do a day trip to
New York when my time comes like just to
do my services like haircut Botox
eyebrows yeah but that kind of goes
against my way of traveling which is
like let's make it a big event Jackie
like will not go somewhere unless she
could bring her entire family which is
like so sweet and cute but like you can
just take a day trip I know I could but
don't you want to see the boys let's
make it a week no of course of course of
course but like just come by yourself
you know you could stay with me true if
you bring all the boys like I don't
think everyone could stay with me no and
I I still have some time on
breastfeeding like I'm starting the
weaning process which takes like weeks
so it's not happening for a while but I
was just thinking about it today we're
just like in such similar stages like
weaning off of OIC weaning off of
breastfeeding like it's kind of amazing
how similar are TR jectories are right
we're both so
clean right yeah except we're getting
Botox it's fine it doesn't count it's
literally medicinal yeah it is it's good
for migraines and Jackie and I were both
also like up in the middle of the night
for different like yeah we're on like
different paths but they are converging
in the middle of the night at 3:00 a.m.
different destinations same
journey I guess you could say that I
like went to bed so early I watched a
little bit of the crown went to bed at
10:00 I woke up at 3:00 to pee and like
I was
up and at 600 I was like okay you know
what I'm going to go to the gym but I
really didn't want to go so I was like
let me just see one last time if I could
fall back asleep and I did so a little
bit more sleep de recently like I
decided in the last few days so Charlie
like wakes up like five six like in a
lot and I've decided I'm just going to
like start my day earlier and stop like
trying to get cuz the other night when
we weren't working like he was up at
6:00 and then didn't go back to sleep
until 8:00 and like if we were working I
should have started my day at 6 but it
was the weekend so it was fine but I'm
like you know what I think I should just
like start starting my day at that early
wake up I'll get so much more done that
trying to get him back to sleep for 2
hours is so like frustrating and I think
I should just get on with it so that's
what I've started to do and it feels
good is that it is nice to have time in
the morning Ben used to do that like
Theo used to wake him up for dinner I
mean breakfast
and Ben would fall back asleep and just
feel like [__] when he woke up yeah you
don't feel any better yeah no you feel
worse when you take that like last chunk
of sleep like it's you're still not
rested so you might as well be
productive and get on with it so that's
a good resolution for me in the new year
is like to start my day earlier and stop
trying to like get that sleep in it's
just not going to love yeah so yeah I
was up to with the Charles and curls and
sleeping through the night is not
happening in my household we kind of
have to address something from
yesterday's episode do
we I just think it's probably best for
our safety if you know you or I don't
take a trip to Detroit in the coming
weeks and months I had no plans they're
not happy with us I shouldn't take a day
trip to Detroit no maybe you can get
your eyebrows down in Detroit they're
not happy with us they're a prideful
City we just kind of took like a massive
dump on them which we do and I just want
to say one thing to Detroit like it's
not your time sit down it's not your
time like for the Super Bowl it's not
your time for toast affection but like
everything things change things evolve
and anything can happen so just stay
hopeful Detroit but stay real with
yourselves yeah stay hopeful stay real
although I do want to say like it really
wouldn't behoove us to be out here like
slamming Detroit we're huge in Detroit
oh right I didn't know that no and it's
nothing it's nothing against the people
of Detroit I could I could see us in
years from now like singing Detroit's
Praises like everything's coming up
Detroit but right now not everything's
coming up Detroit everything's coming up
San Francisco 49ers not San Francisco
the city you're saying Detroit isn't the
name on everybody's lips no and it's the
name on more lips than usual but not
everybody's lips and I feel like we
could agree on that Detroit by the way I
had an idea for a patreon episode let me
know what you think and let me know like
what people in the comments think
actually maybe don't um if we did a fast
five but only Sports cuz I feel like
we're like every every time we sit on
this show like it's almost like our
natural inclination is to talk about
sports it's so crazy yeah I'm so down
maybe if we get it out of our systems in
like an hourong patreon we could go back
to talking about normal stuff here at
the toast unlikely I say we give it a
shot okay there's just just like a lot
going on obviously in the NFL of course
but just in the Sports World in general
we should have our husbands on standby
like on the phone if we have any
questions that come up and we need
answers but like it's so much better to
come up with our own answers yeah but
sometimes you do like it's not even
about answers it's just like opinions
you know they contribute talking head
style so how are the stories today good
I feel good about them feel strong yeah
I do oh she feels strong they came
together I would say today's like story
selection process was an average ideal
perfect day not amazing the stories
right themselves not desperate but just
like five stories that by I wasn't
scratching the bottom of the barrel I
was at four while and I didn't even
realize I was looking for just one more
we got up to six and I took one out o
when when you have six options like your
cup runneth over that's the best feeling
yeah it wasn't hard to take one out yeah
just make the cut yeah it was an ideal
story selection day I have I have no
complaints that's so great I can't even
think of what like could be a story what
happened yesterday let me try and guess
no because then we're going to talk
about it so it's better that you don't
know you won't be super surprised by
anything maybe one oh she a rogue she
something no like maybe one that you
hadn't heard yet that you do need to
know something about a farm and you know
shower do starter I wish ballerina Farm
is still at Mrs Universe she's doing
great even though I don't think she's
competing no she's like a judge no yeah
because she's the current
M America what she's the crown holder so
she's there to Beque it oh my God you
did not tell me that yesterday I I kept
trying to tell you she's Mrs
America oh my God I thought you were
being like your annoying self when
you're like she's literally Mrs America
I was trying to say if you would listen
to me oh no I I was trying to say you
couldn't choose a more perfect Mrs
America wait and I thought that was you
being like when you lost
no no no I was being extremely literal
and I I don't know if she's at Mrs World
competing for Mrs world as Mrs America
or she's there hosting because she's
like such a leader in her field I don't
know and last year when she won Mrs
America like how many followers did she
have is she new like how long has she
been around I feel like she's been
around a a while did you see last night
I started sending you some other
homesteading Trad wives you jaie started
sending me content like from some F I
didn't want to bombard freaks I didn't
want to bombard you but I needed you to
see what's going on like these women
like play dress up except they're not
like this is they're cosplaying in their
lives as you know Little House on the
Prairie but these are women with like
homes with electricity who choose to use
a fire and a like a pot outside a cauld
a cauldron thank you to like make some
baked beans like to me that's just
beyond unnecessary they're filming it
all on their
iPhone Pro Max
no some of the [__] you were sending me
like I wouldn't like I don't even want
to breathe the same breathe ballerina
Farm's name in the same sentence as
these people because the people you sent
me like dead serious Jackie like were
absolute Freaks and also I think you
know not to be like I'm not
saying but it's more impressive like
some of those women like don't have kids
so it's like of course you have the time
to endlessly cook and PR your herbs and
like I don't you know there's time wow
but for me ballerina Farm is extra
impressive because she has now eight
children and she's doing these things
and not to say blah blah blah blah blah
by the way by the way like that it's
crazy how like that's considered a crazy
thing but like I think it's just logical
like if you have eight kids you
obviously have less time in the day than
someone with zero kids like come on
right is what I'm saying and and that's
factual and that's
fair actually we have um a deer toasters
today actually we have two deer toasters
one that sounds like it was written by
you and one that sounds like it was
written by me
I'm so excited that sounds like a great
deer toasters yeah no they're great uh
Wednesday is our day for deer toasters
so please by the way we're running a
little low in submissions like some of
these stink sorry so deer toasters
gmail.com if you want to write to us
also you head over to the toast
podcast.com there's a submission box you
can just submit it right there great
thank you oh my God wait I need to add a
de your toasters
why Jackie do you remember what I sent
you when I was in Mexico
yeah yeah I did do you do you remember
bitmoji oh yeah so take out the one that
doesn't sound like it was written by you
or me oh my God I forgot that somebody
dm'd me the funniest deer toaster
submission they were being dead serious
oh here it is
okay I'm including that I totally forgot
about that I screenshotted it because I
wanted to have it on the show great um
okay so let's dive in because we've got
a lot to do today we do so without
further ad do do about what we have to
do do do here are the fast story stories
that you do do need to know and the fast
live stories that you do do need to know
are brought to you by Thrive Cosmetics
whether you like a fresh faed full Glam
or somewhere in between you've probably
seen Thrive Cosmetics viral tubing
mascara on turties get ready with me cuz
she uses it every day you know it's the
one in the turquoise tube it's all over
social media and it's from Thrive
Cosmetics a brand whose beauty products
are certified 100% vegan and crueltyfree
it's made with clean skin- loving
ingredients high performance and
trademarked formulas and uncompromising
standards in our clean era I feel like
Thrive is like the official mascara of
our clean era I feel like ballerina Farm
totally uses it um so it's easy to see
why all of their bestsellers have
thousands of five star reviews the
mascara that I'm talking about is called
the liquid lash extensions mascara it
lasts all day without clumping smudging
or flaking it is the best mascara I've
ever used now that I have a lash lift I
still use it I'm just using a little bit
less but when my lashes are natural oh
my God I have the worst lashes no
mascara Works my lashes can't hold a
curl and I love this mascara I feel like
it's the best one out on the market also
a big bestseller is their brightening
eye brightener which is a highlighter
stick that's made to brighten and open
your eyes giving you an instant eye lift
you basically apply it to the inner
corner of your eye to look rusted and
effortless I also like to put a little
bit under my brow bone so Thrive
Cosmetics is luxury beauty that gives
back right now you can get an exclusive
20% off your first order at Thrive
cosmetics.com toast that's Thrive
Cosmetics
CA M ts.com toast for 20% off your first
order Thrive
cosmetics.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by liquid IV don't
reinvent yourself for the new year just
rehydrate yourself with liquid IV with
three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink plus eight vitamins
and nutrients for everyday Wellness
liquid IV hydrates you two times faster
than water alone it all comes in a
single sugar-free stick so you can feel
like a hydrated new youu ready to take
on
2024 so liquidy is something you just
always need to have in your house if
you're feeling fatigued if you're
feeling down if you feel like you're
crashing in if you're feeling dehydrated
if you're feeling hung over if you're
feeling you have a migraine it's just a
great thing to always have on hand
because it really will I keep one in my
purse when I travel it really will make
you feel so much more hydrated so much
more alive they have so many good
flavors love the lemon lime I was put it
in my Stanley just a good way like if
you're going to drink water which is
just a horrible experience toss in a
liquid IV it'll make the water work a
lot better it hydrates you two to three
times faster and it makes it taste
better so it's really a win-win for
everyone one stick pours into 16 ounces
of water and it will hydrate you better
than water alone it has three times the
electrolytes no artificial sweeteners
zero sugar eight vitamins and nutrients
and it is nmo free from gluten dairy and
soy so rehydrate yourself for the new
year grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free in bulk Nationwide
a Costco or get 20% off your first order
when you go to liquid i.com and use cod
toast to check out that's 20% off your
first order when you shop better
hydration today using promocode toast at
liquid.com promocode toast today's
episode is also brought to you by bowl
and branch in a recent customer survey
96% said that bowl and Branch sheets get
softer with every wash the sheets are
made with the rarest 100% organic cotton
their signature weave feels buttery and
breathable to start and unlocks new
levels of softness with every wash you
can feel the difference with their 30
night WorryFree guarantee I me I did
something crazy cuz you know I've had
bowl and Branch sheets like for an
eternity the same ones I like the crisp
white I got to different color I got a
different color for like my new
apartment aesthetic you know I was
thinking about getting new color what do
you at so I I want to say it's called
sand it's like off-white you know it's
not that crazy it's not like yellow
still it's a departure it's a departure
but it goes with all my new furniture
which is like a very cool natural Vibe I
might have to do the same it arrived
yesterday it's gorgeous it's literally
gorgeous and it's the same material it's
a signature cheap collection so I know
it feels good I know that it's made well
it gets better with every was but I
change colors like I she's crazy my
sheets get washed tomorrow so I'll have
a photo for you guys tomorrow yeah yeah
I need a photo so they're a bestseller
for a reason you can sleep better at
night with the softest sheets from bowan
Branch get 15% off your first order when
you use promo code toast at Bowen
branch.com that's bowan Branch b o l l a
n d branch.com promo code toast
exclusions to applies to seite for
details they're designed to feel
incredible they come in 13 versatile
colors in all sizes twin up to
California king and they offer a 30
night WorryFree guarantee so you'll get
free shipping and Returns on all us
orders great Ty
CHD YW our first story some Royal news
big news this morning breaking I saw
Kate Middleton has been hospitalized
after abdominal surgery she's cancelled
all engagements until Easter oh my God I
thought you said she's canceled she's
cancell until Easter cool Kensington
Palace announced today out of nowhere
that Kate Middleton earlier this month
underwent a planned abdominal surgery at
the London clinic on the previous day
they said the surgery was successful and
it is expected that she will remain in
hospital for 10 to 14 days before
returning home to continue her recovery
Bas wait that's like a lot of time in a
hospital to recover yeah yeah I guess I
I don't know what the standard is for a
surgery and and I don't we don't know
the extent of what the surgery is what
is it like no I'm saying it sounds like
it was like a pretty major surgery yeah
where they're just like taking an
abundance of caution having her recover
there and then she'll be o until Easter
and then she'll resume her royal
engagements that's like probably lowkey
nice because I feel like as a royal like
you don't get PTO like you you're like
and of course they've like scheduled
Christmas and you know vacation time no
but even Christmas that was her last
public appearance she's working
Christmas right no I feel like they
don't get time off like in in a major
sense like this so it must be crazy I
also feel like the Royals since they
have the best Healthcare on the planet
like the only time in recent memory I
can remember like hearing about a a
Royal's health concerns was philli and
he was literally 700 years old like of
course he was going to have health
issues I feel like this is so this feels
like such a foreign like headline to me
yeah I just hope everything's okay they
didn't say exactly what happened but
that the surgery went well and and all
is expected to be good but I just I
worry you know wait like what kind of
surgery is in your stomach like appendix
appendix but they said abdominal right
and appendix I feel at this point is
very routine like I think you could be
back at work in a week yeah
I don't know see it's a little
concerning mysterious so they they seem
unconcerned and they're just like all's
well surgery went well she's recovering
see you at Easter Easter's kind of far
away no I know so it's not nothing it's
not nothing that's all I'm saying
also I watched two episodes of the crown
last night and they might have been like
two of the worst episodes like for real
is there a is there a lull yes and they
stick an episode in right things are
getting good which okay so I believe is
it okay so the first one that was like
kind of dreadful was William just being
a like a miserable
Brat's at Will's Mania after his mom
died like understandable I'm not mad at
him but like to watch it was painful he
said some like really horrible things to
his dad and then Philip ended up
bringing the back together yeah I think
he had to go through that hard time and
we had to see it for him to become the
man that he is today it's not like he
was just been perfect all his life like
he was a dreadful teenager yes and then
the second episode was the queen was
like think think about reform thinking
about like cutting you know budgets and
making herself look like more common
like the people and then at the last
minute she was like no [__] this I
didn't mind that episode that didn't
come to mind as one of the Dreadful ones
what else happened in that episode
nothing I like hearing about like all
these it's a lot about yes that was by
the way I agree the part where they like
showcase the most random Fringe people
that they employ just really
highlighting like how frivolous their
expenses are um like the warden of the
swans yes I liked that part too but
another big part of this the uh episode
was Tony Blair like as the new prime
minister really popular yeah Serbia I
mean NE neither did the queen but I
didn't find those jobs to be like so
frivolous and they are so rooted in
history it's the same as being you know
having a job at a museum
almost yeah I did think that Tony Blair
like had some good ideas for reformation
like you really should you know put out
every year how much money of taxpayer
dollars you spent but then how much
money you brought in and I think they do
I think they actually do do that now
yeah and they bring in so much money
they bring in more money than they take
so they're in the green right right and
I do think in the last 20 25 years they
did downsize the family that was Charles
initiative and they don't show that on
the show but like everything used to be
the whole family Aunts Uncles cousins
now it's the nuclear family that was
like a Charles decision and they didn't
show that no but it's the right
call yeah not everyone needs to be like
if everyone's so special then nobody's
special you know yeah no it makes sense
and especially as like you know we go
into the future but it's cool to see
those like big portraits Vander pump
rule
style Vander pump Ru style where they
have like every person who ever came
into about the theme song yeah no but
the pum rules did the Charles effect too
and they cut down to just the OG's did
you also think it was strange that they
changed the actors for William and Harry
yeah like it was no time had passed it
was like a week yeah okay so then I had
to Google I'm like wait wait like I was
so confused yeah it was a kind of aird
boys the new actors do not look 12 and
15 no but they needed to make the job
but it didn't feel smooth to me
especially
Harry
especially Harry he's that first of all
that boy in no world is he 12 and also
they're like getting drunk I don't think
Harry was getting drunk at 12 I think he
was and also the drinking age there is
18 so you have to oh you have to adjust
adjust yeah no you're right I don't
think they would have showed them
drinking if they didn't drink at those
ages but the Harry jump was a jump scare
it was a jump scare it just felt
especially because when Diana passed he
was like you know really so young and in
those
before she dies like he's so attached to
her and then he's someone else he
doesn't give a [__] yeah no that actor
came in guns blazing oh and it's worth
mentioning he looks nothing like Prince
Harry did at the time yeah Prince Harry
was like very always cherubic yeah but
as the episodes go on I don't know what
they did they also like Spike his hair
the hair in later episodes the hair is
awful it's more hairy so I think they
like it was
it was a lot but will the the new
William looks a lot like William did at
the time the hair is perfect yeah yeah
he's a good new
William uh I also agree with your
analysis yesterday that the show and I
don't know if it was a goal the show is
extremely complimentary to Prince
Charles I I'm seeing him in a whole new
light it's extremely complimentary
towards Camila too like every time
they're on the phone which is all the
time she's giving him the best advice
yeah like putting the kids first putting
the country first she understands her
role she the voice of reason in the show
in addition to the queen but like she
doesn't step out of line ever she never
gives a bad bit of advice but it also
makes me I was thinking about this
yesterday too because at this point
they're still not married and I am sure
that at one point they wanted to have
children together and the fact that they
like were forced to wait so long to get
married really you know took that option
away from them yeah but that's like not
something it's not just
like a regular person deciding to have
children like that would
just so many questions I don't even
think they can answer I and I'm not a
stepmother but I I believe that being a
stepmother is very fulfilling but I
don't feel like she like cuz the kids by
the time she actually got married like
the kids were so much older and it was
so contentious like I don't I don't
think of her as a a maternal figure to
these boys like at all no I don't think
she tries to be or claims to be or
attempts in any any way because it's
futile and she's like their mother's
Nemesis yeah and I think today it's all
like they have a nice working family
relationship but it's not like motherly
no I wonder if it's
grandmotherly you like the kids in
Camila yeah oh my God I kind of love
that like if that was like her way of
like connecting like through the kids
I'm sure I mean kids bring everyone
together they really do yeah I wonder
what it's like
now yeah also so
um I'm just a random takeaway from the
crown and this was throughout all
different eras is like how they really
like none of them live together like
they don't even live close like the fact
Char castles yeah the fact that Charles
is like in this big old house but then
also weirdly there's like one complex
where a million cast members Liv like
Diana lives Margaret Liv what's that
place called the red building and by the
way William and Kate currently live
there no they just moved to Windsor but
they lived there before before was it
Kensington yes yes yes thank you yeah um
like it's like an apartment style yeah
but no Diana's house looked real nice I
kind of liked that yeah but she's like
neighbors with Margaret and other oh
family members Queen Margaret like from
she was like a more of a main character
in early seasons and now she just pops
in every now and then and everything she
says is just brilliant and and on the
money and I just love her yeah Princess
Margaret yeah what did I say queen fry
and slip no cuz she's a queen in my eyes
yeah she is but she could never be Queen
no no no no no no would you rather be
like a William or a Harry a Margaret or
an Elizabeth the one who Bears the
burden or the one who literally has like
a life that's meaningless it's not it
literally does not have to be
meaningless and I think it depends but
they always end up seeing it that way
there's no right
answer a blanket right answer you have
to look in Inward and be like what kind
of person are you you know I'm a
sovereign I'm a sovereign oh you think
you're not a Margaret no I couldn't
really like live in like someone else's
Shadow like for real oh that's true but
like do you have the
Constitution to be the one if you're
like the spare who ends up getting like
a lot of attention like that's
bad like when Margaret was all all that
drama then of course Harry like they
never want that you're just supposed to
behave that's why but the Sovereign is
not meant to be a star when you have a
star Sovereign you have problems no it's
true I think I'm The
Sovereign of course he would I think I'm
the
Sovereign but it's not necessarily a
good thing like Queen Elizabeth
isn't boisterous fun yeah the boisterous
Queen Elizabeth no one ever said said no
one ever I don't know why you can't be
boisterous in your personal life do you
think she was you'd haven't gotten to
this conversation yet and I'm not going
to try to explain it because it's going
to sound stupid but at a certain point
okay fine she's talking to
her younger self at one point in the
show and and Queen Elizabeth is like you
know I I want to see Elizabeth Windsor
again and like Be That Girl Again and
you know I had to set her aside to be
the queen and her younger self is like
there's no two girls anymore like you're
just the one Queen Elizabeth so you
can't have be one way in your personal
life and another way publicly like it
has to be all encompassing could you do
it I would I would Usher the monarchy
into a new era where like we're all
personality hires and we're all funny
and we all have podcasts and we're all
influencers and we all have phones and
we're fun and we're not serious and
maybe like everyone in London wouldn't
hate us no but that works for a time
what goes up must come down it's it's
about the consistency of it I don't care
and what if you're so fun with your
podcast then get cancelled the monarchy
can't be canell now the Royals are
interesting they're already interesting
and I'd be bringing in so much revenue
for the country
I I I think as the number two you'd be
amazing that's just like a really weird
thing to say no you would be like
because you also you have
that I wouldn't mind being like a
Kate yeah Mar
maral lots of responsibility though and
no aside from this no days off yeah but
I was able to have like a somewhat
normal upbringing at like I'm still a
normal person in my brain like if you're
a royal from day one like you're not
normal like no it's impossible to be
right so I wouldn't mind being a Kate I
also would not mind being a Megan right
I think that's good and Outsider coming
in you know yeah a coma if you right but
don't you feel like if you know what the
outside world is like and now you have
to come into this warped world it's
maybe harder than if you don't really
know any different okay okay okay we're
just conversing no you're just like that
was a question not a statement every
every corner just like punching me right
in the gut like okay you're right like
okay I'll just shut the [__] up no I'm
just trying to have a conversation and
what do you think about that you could
say to me no I think it's better this
way okay it's called dialogue tury it's
our job okay how about this I won't
become a royal okay no but now I think
now I think you're denying the world I
mean that I the thing is like when
you're a royal in your own mind like the
queen of your own heart it doesn't
really matter matter titles schmidel
exactly by the way you do know and I
think we discussed this that one of the
cousins is married to a rugby player who
has a podcast yes we have spoken about
this CU she was at I forget what the
last big Affair was perhaps a coronation
and she kind of stole the show yeah so I
just always think like there's
podcasters within the
family yeah it could happen for you tury
it
could anyways we'll continue our Crown
recap when you finish it yeah yeah yeah
a few days few days are you ready for
our next story other big news from
yesterday MH the Coachella 2024 lineup
has been announced the headliners are
Lana Del re Tyler the Creator and doat
and dot dot dot no doubt question
they're like the Afterparty headliner
right they didn't say it's just at the
bot they're like at the bottom yeah they
I don't think they know in what capacity
no doubt will be performing they just
let you know know that they'll be there
I feel really happy and excited for the
girlies who love Lana Del re cuz I feel
like if you love Lana Del re you get
like almost no opportunities to live out
that fandom I feel like she never tours
I don't know she's like so mysterious to
me yeah I agree I think she's a really
good get she's got a great cult
following and it does overlap a lot with
the
Coachella person Vibe yeah by the way
like the the vend diagram of Ladell Ray
fans and Coachella ticket holders is
just a circle right so I think this is
smart Tyler the Creator also has a lot
of fans he's actually my number one most
listened to artist right now do you
think he's going to sing at Harry's
favorite song You're a Mean One Mr
Grinch You're a mean one you really are
a you're as
Charming as an
eel how does that we listen to that all
day every day and I I just have to say
it could be better I agree so I was
introduced to like the new Grinch for
kids soundtrack while we were all on our
family trip because all the kids love
princh and I was like oh this music
sucks and your husband was telling me
like no it's amazing it was done by
farel and I just think
like not everything forel does is going
to be amazing you know yeah like they
remixed the classic You're a Mean One Mr
Grinch Mr
Grinch oh I just got a notification that
King Charles is going into be undergoing
a corrective procedure no sh I don't
know we'll get to that anyway so what we
were saying they remixed that song which
is such a Bop and the remix like it
really could be so much better it's not
great and it's ripe for
greatness oh my God wait I was checking
my people notifications too listen this
is a crazy people notification did you
get this Ray dond has a breaking news re
dond has breaking news a breaking pie
recipe that's what people no this is
even crazier Jennifer Aniston channeled
Rachel Green with a wardrobe stable and
you missed that notification I know like
how can you go on I don't know how can
the show go on should I add it to the
fast Vibe like it's kind
of like what's the point in even doing
the show if I missed such aak a
groundbreaking story like for real I'm
devastated I have been meaning to turn
off My People magazine notifications for
every one decent do you get the Charles
one even no so here's what's even more
interesting about People magazine oh
they're going to send you for a day
about like Amazon vacuums we found on
sale but oh let's say literally Queen
Elizabeth died they're two hours late
like with actual breaking news it's the
biggest wayte I I need to get rid of it
I just I can't bring myself maybe you
have like a preference turned on where
like you want soft news not hard news it
definitely feels that that I have some
sort of preference on but it's not your
preference you're saying it's not my
preference and this isn't my plate no it
never was and it never will be okay
let's get back to the Coachella
Headliners oh yeah who was the third
doat doic cat which is awesome no that's
really awesome so here's the thing each
individual performer like is actually a
really good choice but I think overall
like this
stinx yeah there's not like a a Lady
Gaga or a Beyonce and a lot of people
were like speculating that Taylor was
going to head Lon Coachella like every
now and then they did yeah actually not
even every now then for the last couple
of years it has been like the weekend
Justin Bieber Billy eyelish the last day
has been like a mega mega mega and doic
Cat's amazing like
Beyond but she's not on that level no
she's on her way I think actually her
set will be amazing because everybody
knows all of her songs they're all so
popular perform you don't even realize
how many you know like just from the
culture it's crazy so the headliners are
good but then like when you get into the
the smaller text yeah like who was on
the second and third lines I know rap is
on there which is actually very exciting
she's on the third line so I'm going to
just read the people that we know from
the other lines and so line two of day
one Lil Uzi vert line three Sabrina
Carpenter Steve
Angelo yeah line four Suki
Waterhouse and then the rest of the
people we personally don't know then the
next day line two ice
spice oh that's pretty big line two
beachers Grimes John
batist oh John batist okay Grimes I
wonder if Elon will be there even though
they're in a custody battle I can't keep
up with those two like for real I know
cuz she was in his book like she's with
him all the time they're so sympatico I
didn't even talk about his book I talked
about it more on the redheads because
there's so much pop culture stuff
because he like dates everyone the Amber
herd days were dark in what sense like
their relationship was so toxic and he
kind of gravitates towards toxic
relationships but but apparently she did
a number on him like when they broke up
like he was not okay for I don't know
what I don't know if it was like
heartbreak or just trauma trauma but it
was not flattering towards Miss Amber
herd and then Grimes kind of comes in
and is his twin flame and they're so
stico they have three kids together and
she in every step like when he's you
know stealing not stealing but like
literally he had to like take his like d
Twitter data servers and they like
pulled them up from where they were
stored and like move them somewhere else
like she's in the car with him sitting
on in the back seat with X on her lap
like she does everything with him and
now they're in a custody battle it is
cute but present day doesn't isn't
congruous with what I read in the book
that's sad yeah anyway she's performing
at Coachella and then day I mean line
three day two nothing more that I see
that I that I know yeah it's not like
the craziest most amazing thing they're
really missing that like one big star
I guess so I guess so but BB rexa will
be there I love her yeah she doesn't
have a bad song but I also feel like for
Coachella like you need really solid
music but it's also a lot about the
experience too and I feel like people
who already bought tickets like they
don't really care too much yeah like I I
even if Taylor was headlining Coachella
like I don't know if I would go
Coachella is just not something you
either want to go or you don't you know
what I mean Taking Back Sunday will be
there on Sunday that's act they're like
you know emo band oh okay Ben Ben would
like them
um but yeah I agree it's like M Jay
Balvin was the other one oh I feel like
he would be on line one
yeah he's that by the way that would
like fill like check up the box like the
weekend Billy eish like he's on that
level yeah well he's like right before
DOA cat on the third day so that that
will be like a big evening he's like in
my opin opinion like much bigger than
Tyler the
Creator yeah in my
opinion and also of the three Headliners
we have I feel as though Lana Del Rey
should go last but maybe this works best
for her
schedule but like if you're going to be
a headliner like the last night is like
the big one that's like what you want
it's true but it's also Sunday it's
typically Easter Sunday and maybe she's
like a religious girly and doesn't want
to perform on Easter Sunday when is
Easter we're talking a lot about Easter
today I know everyone hype for Easter he
is rising Easter March
31st what in
March is that crazy kind of Easter so
April when's Passover so April and then
Passover begins on April 22nd almost a
full month
later oh they're usually sisters
Mercury's in
retrograde you guys things are actually
that means we got a holiday in
March that's true even though like we're
not going to take off for Easter for
Good Friday I don't know tur it's good
no I don't think we've ever taken off
for Good Friday that's like cultural
appropriation sound off in the comments
would you be
offended yeah would you be offended if
we put ashes on our forehead and took
off the day are you offended that you
conflated Ash Wednesday with Good Friday
oh [__] I got my days confused but isn't
Ash Wednesday like one day before Good
Friday too yeah I think they're related
they're not unrelated they're part of
the same holiday
yeah God
bless so for everyone going to Coachella
hope you have a blast hope you listen to
awesome music and drink awesome Shooters
and soak up each other's awesomeness
agreed that would actually be a great
segue into our next story which I'm
going top about me girls it's about Mean
Girls because Lindsay Lohan has pulled
down a fetching Payday for her Mean
Girls movie musical Cameo variety is
reporting that she pulled down $500,000
for half a day of work in the late
iteration of the movie Musical that
stars Renee rap Andre rice and others at
all I also heard that there was a joke
in the movie that she was very unhappy
with because it was at her expense yeah
I didn't I saw the headline but I don't
know where if she said she was unhappy
or it's like sources you know specul
yeah yeah but I saw that too I guess she
didn't know about it even though she's
in the movie yeah but if somebody paid
me $500,000 like you could say whatever
you want
yeah yeah but you get a script if you're
just like an extra I guess you probably
do if you want you get like your script
from your scene oh I'm sure you could
request a script for the whole movie but
really who wants that like no totally
but you're even me homework no and it's
like she knows the
script right she doesn't need to approve
the script I have heard very mixed
reviews about Mean Girls I've only heard
good things I have heard good things
about um the character who plays Janice
Ian I heard she kind of steals the show
same with Daman I've heard that Katie
was
miscast and of course Renee rap stole
the show if you miss cast
Katie the movie can't be 100% yeah
because it's funny based on like the
press and the marketing like you would
think that Renee rap is the main
character of this movie but Regina's
actually not no it's Katie herenz yeah I
heard I haven't heard much but the
little I've heard is that it was really
like good enjoyable nostalgic you know
it might not be making any new Mean
Girls fans but for the existing Mean
Girls fans it's it's really
enjoyable I'm definitely going to see it
me
too take myself to the to the theater on
Wednesdays you're wearing pink
la oh my God I am that's like so
losery yeah that's why I didn't do it
yeah sure wouldn't be caught dead yeah
sure now are you ready for our next
story what number is this four
yeah I think you're going to you're
going to like this story because it's
about
Joan oh what did she do now Melissa
Rivers said that Joan Rivers would have
loved OIC she said it's her two least
favorite things would have loved OIC
Melissa said her two favorite things
were diet and exercise her two least
favorite things sorry oh my God that is
so funny yeah so Melissa Rivers is
getting candid about her late Mom Joan
who died unexpected L nearly a decade
ago rest in peace Our Queen so Melissa
who hosts the celebrity chat Show
podcast called Melissa Rivers's group
text opened up in this week's
issue of people about what she wishes
she could tell her mom about the world
today while also joking about things her
mom would not be excited about she said
she would not have bought into
athleisure and people wearing sweatpants
everywhere she'd be like no you still
get dressed you pull yourself together
you put on a little lip gloss and then
you go out she said but she would have
been very very excited by Body
acceptance that would have actually made
her really happy she also admits her mom
would have equally enjoyed the new glp1
weight loss drugs like OIC wovi and
mangaro she said oh she would have
thought OIC was the greatest thing since
sliced bread her two least favorite
things were diet and exercise so she
could find a way to avoid both awesome
no the thing is is that there are a lot
of people reaping the benefits of these
types of medications but nobody is
reaping the benefits more than older
Jewish women yeah who have struggled
with their weight like genetically on
like a chemical level since they were
bored why are people now calling it gp1
like they started last week yeah because
like there's so many like you can be on
mararo wovi ozempic semaglutide tripati
and this is just a way of saying all of
them of grouping them because I thought
the group was
semaglutide no uh manjaro's active
ingredient is not semaglutide it's
tritide look at you Elizabeth zot yeah
no I know everything there is to know
about OIC and I actually just recorded a
solo podcast episode on the patreon
about my journey with OIC if you're
interested in hearing more
um but you know another thing that Joan
would hate in this day and age um what's
going on in Israel yeah no like the
radicalization of gen Z and like
becoming lovers of terrorist
organizations like if Joan was around we
she'd be vomiting I'm glad that she's
not I know but I'm glad that she's not
alive to see it however a voice like
hers is of the utmost necessity in this
moment I agree with both I would love to
hear a Joe and write like a five minute
standup monologue on Americans
protesting outside Sloan ketering cancer
hospital because they accepted a
donation from a Jew like that is really
um like what I personally need in this
moment yeah but I'm glad she's not
around to see it it's really sickening
one of my favorite um fact about myself
and actually it's about both of us is
that you and I have been inside Joan
River's apartment yeah the apartment
like everyone knows her apartment also I
feel as though a few years ago we
reported that um a production company
had posthumously bought the rights to
like hours and hours and hours of
unaired Joan Rivers standup like recent
stuff and that they were going to be
releasing specials and stuff and albums
and we never got that do you remember I
don't remember that I remember because
the production company that
had bought it was called comedy Dynamics
and they produced my first special
that's why I like made the story about
myself I remember so why don't you text
them and ask I mean like I could but
like who wants to bother people you know
yeah it seems like you have the in I
just does anybody else remember that
story I actually don't I just remember
you really don't the Joan biopic that's
not getting made what's that Katherine
Han oh yes what was that cuz she's not
Jewish I mean that was a bad casting I'm
not going to lie yeah but like I would
go for a non-jewish Joan if it's a good
casting yeah yeah but who would play
Joan honestly the lady from hacks Jean
Jean's smart I think her name but what
if you want to go younger like the ear
like when she was on that uh Johnny
Carson yeah oh I guess if we're doing
like a Coming of Age Joan then the
person doesn't really need to look like
and you know I love Joan but she was uh
somebody who had a lot of reconstru RVE
surgery and I do think that that look
could be achieved with prosthetics like
the person doesn't need to look that
much like her yeah in her later years so
they just need to be the best person for
the job and for me that doesn't need to
be someone Jewish it'd be great if it
was but I just want the best movie
possible it needs to be somebody who is
so naturally funny cuz yeah the script
is going to be great but so what was so
Jon was like her mannerisms and just
like her off the cuff so who's like an
actor or actress who like we know just
like in interviews and stuff is funny
like you need need to have that
yeah kind of like like maybe like
Jennifer Lawrence is that
crazy yeah no that's she's not funny
enough but n that's not so crazy
actually and she's a really good actress
and then it would be a good movie and
that's I want a good movie yeah I want a
movie that feels like a real movie yeah
is that so much ask for it's not are you
ready for our fifth and final story no
no why our fifth and final story is
brought to you by vegamore isn't that
crazy it's not crazy when you look at
our hair real change happens when you're
consistent and achieving the hair of
your dreams is no exception thanks to
vegamore sticking to our hair routines
has never been easier and we are finally
seeing the results that we've always
wanted so vegamore products are 100%
cruelty-free And are never formulated
with potentially harmful chemicals like
parabens or hormones when it comes to
seeing results the key is consistency so
we've made it a part of our daily
routine for me that grow serum I
experienced a lot of hair thinning and
shedding over the last couple last year
and vegamore um when I needed like a
topical Serum vegamore is what I went
with the grow serum gr it's a part of
the grow kit it comes with shampoo and
conditioner I love that serum there are
a lot of serums on the market I find
that vegamore results were fabulous but
also it doesn't make your hair oily so a
lot of the serums like you have to put
it in and then wash your hair like we're
washing our hair twice a week we don't
have time but you have to do the serum
every day that's really why I like the
big more one it dries down and your hair
looks completely fine having the monthly
subscription to the grow hair serum
makes it really easy to stay consistent
so when you sign up for the monthly
subscription you can get one bottle or
three bottle scent plus you're saving
more and you're never running low on the
products that you need to take care of
your hair so elevate your hair Wellness
routine this year with vegamore for a
limited time get 20% off your first
subscription by going to vore.com toast
and using Cod toast to check out that's
v g m o r.com toast Cod toast to save
20% on your first order that's vegamore
v g m o u r com/ toast Cod toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content all in one time all in one
place all on your own terms so it's time
that you got a website girlfriend
whether you have a side business you
work in e-commerce you're an artist a
graphic designer there's a million
reasons why you would want to have a
website but it's just a great place to
acquire new customers showcase your work
and Squarespace is the place to do it
because starting a website can be
extremely intimidating extremely
expensive and extremely difficult like
some people go to college for four years
to figure that out Squarespace you just
need a computer and a dream you know
they have amazing assets like uh selling
custom merch creating an online store
showcasing a video collection sending
out email campaigns um but mostly it's
great for e-commerce so if you sell
online they also have a point of sale so
if you go to like a trade show where you
want to sell in person you can do so by
connecting a square reader to the
Squarespace app and it'll keep all your
orders your inventory and your customer
data in sync with your online store so
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's squarespace.com toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain thank you la you're
welcome our fifth and final story is
little breakup news that at first made
me sad but now that I'm learning more I
hate oh okay summerhouse star Sam fer
Feer confirms her breakup with Corey
kefir so they got together on last
season of Summer House Sam was the new
girl on summer house Corey was a friend
of Craigs they started flirting and
getting along last season we all saw on
the show and then they started seriously
dating and they were dating for about a
year and a half but now they've broken
up and Sam went on not skinny but not
podcast and spilled the beans and
explained like literally to a te what
went wrong and and I understand and I
hate I was like really sad that these
two broke up like I thought they were so
cute together and it actually really
thought that they had potential to like
you know take it all the way yeah I
thought so too but she revealed that she
ended their relationship a few days
before Christmas after processing his
shenanigans on winter house so she said
on the podcast quote I'm not even here
to talk [__] I think he's great I didn't
break up with him because I don't love
him I broke up with him because he
doesn't love me and that's that she
later admitted that she would tell him
that she loved him but he never set it
back over the course of their
relationship she said that was like a
really big problem for me I was like I
think I need to get out it's becoming
clear she explained that he was shocked
in floid when she called him before the
holidays and dumped him the split came
after the two of them who were doing
long-distance relationship they hadn't
communicated for 48 hours after he
didn't respond to her test text asking
him to spend New Year's Eve with her
family she said when your long-distance
boyfriend doesn't communicate with you
for 48 hours and there's nothing wrong
then there's something wrong like that's
so weird why do you want to go 4 48
hours without talking to me at all like
that's so crazy yeah no it's almost like
once she stopped making the effort like
they never spoke right she said he call
she calls him shortly afterwards and he
claimed that he accused her of testing
him and timing their texts she said
that's the kind of gaslighting I don't
need in my life she added that specific
moment was the first time she knew she
was making the right decision she said
we were talking and talking and he was
like what are you saying are you saying
we should break up and I was like yeah
then there was silence she said that he
was really mature about the split and
apologized to her but the only thing
that has continued to bother her is he
told her I wish it was different and all
she could think about is you don't wish
badly enough to treat me right like you
can wish all you want but if you would
do anything to change How It Was Then
you can do the bare minimum he was like
I can do anything except that also this
is after winter house has been airing
and he was
acting unfavorably towards her like
saying they weren't official which they
I guess she said they were in a
situationship not official official but
like he was acting
disrespectfully and she saw that all
play out and so he's a [__] boy like in
every in every sense of the word and
like we could have guessed that like he
just gives off the vibe of like someone
who cheats on their girlfriend like
which sucks not even cheats but just
like he even said in one of his
confessionals that they weren't you know
serious yet and so he was going to put
like every guy no one wants to be in a
relationship so you kind of push it as
long as you can until the girl forces
you to be in one it's like that's not
how a good relationship works but I feel
like what we saw of their relationship
last season like yeah he was giving kind
of like [__] boy Vibes but she like the
perfect type of girl to cuz she's so fun
like you know that she would just
naturally he would want to be always
having this fun with her and naturally
they would become like an official item
which is how it started but I guess you
know really a leopard couldn't change
his spots no I'm like lowkey so excited
for the upcoming season of Summer House
mostly because of Carl and Lindsay it's
like it's actually so crazy
yeah and apparently like it's all on
camera yeah yeah that's what we've read
I think it might have aired the first
episode or it's like no the the trailer
just came out the yeah no I'm like there
would have been more Fanfare if the
episode was out yeah yeah so that will
be good and I guess we'll see Sam and
Corey too I really really liked them I
really like her just as a as a reality
star in general I don't have like that
much space in my heart left for like
more reality stars cuz I have my
favorites already but she really wormed
her way in who's your favorite reality
star of all
time it's it's fluid because I go
through ups and downs with people you
know it's true it's true Karen huger's
up there for me like for a long time
like it was like darit but right now I'm
not really watching Beverly Hills like I
I right but I I always love her but some
people just have like bigger moments for
me it's true it come that's a good point
it comes in waves yeah um okay so those
were the past five you certainly needed
to know them and continuing with our
weekly tradition today is Wednesday
which means deer toasters our weekly
advice segment where we will give advice
to the girlies in need dear toasters
gmail.com is the email you can write
into we'll always keep your [__]
Anonymous do not worry this is the
craziest thing on the planet hello
girlies longtime listener I'm in need of
some husband advice from two married
girlies I found out that my husband has
a secret Reddit troll account he will go
to threads go off alak Carin I saw him
comment on a thread that was about
someone's love for Steve Irwin and my
husband apparently didn't agree with
that
I have a severe ick and I don't know
what to
do being a chronic user of Reddit to the
point where you have your own account is
a sign of mental illness it is and if
this were your boyfriend I would say
break up with your boyfriend but it's
your husband so we need to work on
things because there's a lot that has
gone into this relationship and and it's
so funny I was literally thinking this
morning cuz I saw something on Tik Tok
about like a redit thread not about me
about someone else and I was thinking
like people who really do like create
their own usernames on Reddit and like
start threads and like start drama and
start rumors like are are violent people
like it's only a matter of time like
this is just step one you know they're
they're a danger to themselves and to
those around them they're danger to
society but do you think they could be
rehabilitated I think like and I I know
I sound crazy like I do think like it
requires therapy I was going to suggest
therapy I also think it's an addiction
for a lot of people like they go on
Reddit just to like you know see some
gossip and next thing you know like
they're literally posting people's
addresses like it is a slippery slope
and I do think it's an addiction and I
think it's something that you have to
like cleanse yourself like a vape
seriously like you have to go cold
turkey and I think therapy would help I
I actually like I do I do worry for your
safety for real yeah I was going to
suggest therapy I agree that it's an
addiction I do think you can be
rehabilitated you know I'm a Believer in
change and he needs help this is
unacceptable you can't just
and be like a parent who like talks [__]
on like oh how frightening you're
raising children that's frightening oh
how
frightening no I completely agree
and
yeah yeah I I'll pray for you but I and
I'm glad that you that you like found
out about this and realized how crazy it
was cuz some people would be like oh
he's just like using a social media app
reddit is not a social media app it's
honestly like a breeding ground for
domestic terrorists for real like you
have to get it radicalizes you you have
to get off the platform yeah it's it's
easy to spiral but I think you can be
pulled back I really do think there's
Rehabilitation yeah no change is
possible Freedom stay strong stay strong
let us know what happens all right this
is the one that sounds like you could
have written it in maybe like a year ago
okay dear Jackson Claude I'm 30 live in
Chicago and I'm expecting my first baby
I do not have my driver's license I
always planned on getting it when I
eventually moved to the suburbs my
husband's aom totally supports it but
recently every time we've seen one of
his friends and his wife they like
lecture me about not driving and we saw
them a few weeks ago and the friend
straight up said to me what kind of mom
are you you can't drive and you're going
to be a stay-at-home mom he said it in
front of a big group of people and it
was so humiliating I don't know how to
keep defending my choice and now I'm
wondering if I should just suck it up
and get my license even though I really
don't want it sincerely a soon to be mom
feeling judged okay I understand why you
feel judged I also understand why it's a
crazy concept to be a stay-at-home mom
who can't drive and and we need to be
able to drive and I I really there are
two things going on here yeah like the
comment you should get your license
we'll deal with him but you should get
your license especially if you're going
to move to the suburbs and have a child
like you need to know how to drive for
even if you don't want to drive every
day like for emergency situations you
need to know how to drive at least until
until Elon fully completes automated
driving which she's working on
vigorously so wal but still you need to
have your license in order to get in the
front seat of a self-driving car so you
need to get your license even though I
know it's you don't want to do it I
didn't want to do it and I still I don't
love the driving like I dread it and I
hope one day it gets better but it's
been a year well I guess I took six
months off so it's been six months and I
still like it's not my favorite but when
it's good it's great so you need to
learn how to drive him he can rot yeah I
think we should take a moment and just
be grateful that like you know you're
not married to this man you know but
like it was actually it sounds really
rude and I actually think you should say
something I am the type of person to
like really like slip things under the
rug like I'm I'm nothing ever bothers me
enough to the point where I would ever
say something like I'm so averse to
confrontation but this is like a
particularly disgusting thing and I feel
like you should make him apologize
nothing makes men more uncomfortable
than like having to apologize to a girl
so I think like you should have your
husband say like you owe my wife an
apology you should I like brush things
under the rug and one of two things
happens I genuinely forget about it and
move on beautiful or I never forget and
every time I look at your face I see
that comment and it will affect how I
treat you for the rest of your days and
doesn't isn't that terrible for you love
no but like I think you should say
something like I really do what kind of
mom are
you
what kind of animal are you yeah no that
but how do you even like defend yourself
against an allegation such as that it's
beneath you I know but like I just
really don't like letting people get
away with being animals you know
yeah like let's hold them
accountable I don't know if it's
possible so are you just like expand
expending like mental energy on a lost
cause and maybe best if he doesn't get
invited to your Round Table anymore okay
so that's actually my signature move and
Ben hates it if somebody does something
to me that like I dislike I won't work
it out with them like I will never see
that person again unless it's like a
lifelong friend but if it's like a new
acquaintance who I was like starting to
like whatever this like if you just say
something weird or like do something I'm
like it's not worth I barely know you no
it's more than weird it's offensive
offensive a betrayal I just will slowly
walk backwards and you'll never see me
again yeah it's the terity special Ben
hates it Ben is like just talk it out
talk it out what am I going to talk it
out for like there's nothing s to we're
saving here we were on our way we were
building something yeah but Abandoned
Ship there's just it's talk it out let
her know how you feel like yeah I'm like
no no no literally no and you know what
like we're good it's working for us
we're good I feel like I really do like
I'm not in a position where like I need
more people in my life like if I never
if my circle never got bigger like I
would have a very very full group of
friends and family around me so anyone
at this point who's coming into my life
is just an addition you know it's just
extra sprinkles on top it's not a
necessity so if you're like new here and
you're already like starting stuff like
I'm it's you're not worth the effort
yeah all right this is the third and
final deer toaster that made me laugh so
[__] hard is this the one written by
tury no I ex that one because I like the
other two better and this one I had to
put in hey guys absolutely love you you
are so funny I'm in high school and you
make me laugh every day anyways you just
put it in to let people know we have a
listener in high school I swear to God
Jackie she wrote that I'm in high school
no no I'm saying like we needed to do
this one so that our listeners could
know like we are in higho we are hip and
we are young anyways at Christmas time I
saw my whole family my aunt accused me
of stealing her phone and changing her
bit Emoji to have short hair I didn't by
the way I am baffled that she would
accuse me of this I have heard through
the grap find that she's currently
planning a revenge on me what should I
do to her for making this gross
accusation now there is nothing worse
than being accused of something you
didn't do especially something as
egregious as changing a bemoji because
when it comes like there are a lot of
people who like bitmojis but bitmojis
were really created for Elder ants yeah
the only people I know Who currently use
B emojis are our ants it's just a fact
of life right and Dana holsberg oh love
cuz it's it's integrated with Snapchat
so if your aunt like thinks that you
actually did this like I would
understand why she would be upset like
this is an egregious crime to an aunt
but at the end of the day the truth is
what matters most and you're saying that
you didn't do it and I believe you the
truth will set you free so we just have
to get her to see the truth maybe there
was an update I feel like sometimes that
happens where Emoji updates its look
yeah and people's bit emojis Chang you
should find an article check out Tech
crunch maybe bit Emoji had an update
yeah but also like it's not on you to
prove your innocence like you didn't do
anything you know what I mean like your
aunt just kind of being liist like it's
kind of disgusting that's how I felt
about the guy with the driving comment
like it's not on you to prove that
you're a good like you shouldn't have to
prove your innocence I feel as though
the situations are different but I hear
what you're saying but I actually feel
like in this situation like you could
prove your innocence whereas in that
situation it's like it's it's not on you
to do that but here like you could prove
it somehow find a way yeah but if she's
planning revenge on
keystrokes if you're if she's planning
revenge on you like you're about to find
yourself in like a full-blown prank war
and you have to be prepared cuz those
sometimes can end badly yeah somebody
takes it too far
yeah what do you think is like a good
harmless
prank I'm not actually I weirdly as much
as I say I don't like pranks tacos at
trouts I love a prank like that like a a
prank of the mind yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like to tell you something
completely untrue just to be like
kidding yeah no that's not a prank so
much as it is just a lie yeah but I
don't like think of it in advance it's
like if you ask me it's on the spot
messing with people literally one of my
greatest lie pranks of all time just so
off the cuff when I told bed I sat next
to Rory maoy on my flight home from
Scottdale right or that guy with the
phone number Luke Holmes the the B jul
Rand yeah yeah what did Luke Holmes have
to do with it that I said Ben was like
talking about Julius frandle I was like
oh my God like I literally know Julius
frandle I have his phone number Ben's
like no you don't I said yes I swear to
God I met him backstage he's a big Luke
Holmes fan yeah that's my favorite kind
of prank yeah yeah
yeah let me try and think of like other
funny ones we've
done oh wait I feel like we just just
did one in on our family trip yeah we
were trying to Ben to Ben what was it
h I
forget he didn't he didn't believe it
though he didn't fall for it he's
getting better when we first met him he
was such an easy target yeah oh it was
good those were the days but it didn't
take whatever this one was not even
worth remembering anyways those are to
say Our advice to you girlfriend is to
keep your head up high don't let anyone
like talk on your name especially if
it's not true so stand up for yourself
tell your [__] of an aunt that it
wasn't [__] you and she better back
off or you're going to put n in her
shampoo bottle no you're not soan wrap
on her toilet see
it now see these are pranks I hate now I
hate pranks now I hate them like girls
like this wasn't a prank this was more
like bullying like girls at Camp who
would pee in like other girls shampoo
bottles no yeah that's
like good on a watch list and like
putting their toothbrush in the toilet
disgusting dipping it in the water
that's disgusting yeah those girls are
on Reddit
now those girls are on Reddit now but I
didn't know anyone who ever like that
stuff was kind of stuff of fable you
know people didn't actually do stuff
like that oh are you're talking about
like the peeing in the yeah it's like
stuff you saw in movies you get kicked
out of camp or something that's not like
a harmless prank yeah no you heard like
oh my god did you hear about the girl at
moden who like you would hear like a
rumor but you would never like know that
it's actually true yeah that was like
mythical Camp pranks yeah that's true no
one actually did stuff like that in my
experience yeah I don't know any
firsthand like experiences of people who
did that yeah or who were victims of
that yeah so that's our show thanks to
everyone who wrote in we hope we helped
in a small way and just know that you
know bitemoji stealing is not a
victimless
crime thank you so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up or also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found that's
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio I
radi cast box all the places have you
listen to podcast find to five about a
beautiful studing and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing
Wednesday and we'll see you tomorrow
like Thursday how we sees that just like
that love love you
bye